we've already had neo gravity rush to
persona 5 and horizon zero dawn this
year already and it's only April well
there is another twenty ps4 exclusives
coming your way very soon many of which
are still to be given a release date I
picked seven for you to look at we
should be coming to you over 2017 and
through to 2020 ok let's do this I'm
starting off with spider-man ps4 which
is a working title from insomniac I'm
sure they would like to release this
game around the same time as the latest
spider-man film which hits cinemas in
early July by the way but it's pretty
safe to say it's far too soon and we'll
probably hear more about this one at e3
in terms of gameplay the makers have
hinted at the inclusion of parkour
elements like they'll seen in watchdogs
- or Mirror's Edge who have me runs in
their forward I will call spider-man
Peter parkour yeah did the suit Spidey
wears in this outing it's already
causing division with the fanbase but I
quite like it what do you think although
we only have a teaser for this one we
are told that if you'd open world and
therefore you hold the fate of 9 million
New Yorkers in your web slinging hand
what could go wrong bids beards are the
coolest thing you see on a person
especially women look at this sexy
bastards beard
yes it's Kratos Phoebus where was that
oh yes the God of War reboot I'm sure
you already know about Kratos and his
God murdering axe well he's a man living
outside of those acts now raising his
son we've already seen him teaching his
little frog how to hunt what are you
doing our guards are and he still has
the ability to straight up murder fools
if he needs to go there
if you count collections and PS Vita
games there have been a total of 10 God
of War games spanning 12 years without
looking how many can you name I can do
both they're gone or how I've been
looking forward to this zombie epic in
this one you play an outlaw biking in
Deakin State John who is trying his best
to grow a beard did I mention that
beards are cool anyway you are tasked
with surviving the zombie apocalypse
just look at the amount of zombies which
are chasing you expect your ps4 to blow
up trying to process all that I do
expect this game to run far better on
ps4 Pro by the way and with the release
of the Xbox copy oh we miss by that the
ps4 Pro has a price drop or is that
wishful thinking India's gone you'll be
scavenging and will regularly stumble
across all the humans who may not be as
helpful as you would like
[Music]
so dark we are assured the motorcycle
plays a huge part in this game so
imagine sons of anarchy and The Walking
Dead mixed together and you will be in
the zone it is scheduled for release
this year and I do believe this one
probably just in time for Christmas are
you sick of playing zombie games yet let
me know in the comments below
personally I can't get enough of those
on Dead buggers
come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
gran turismo is a game series that once
ruled the world but fell from grace over
the years they've missed so many release
dates it's become unfathomable and the
cut-down content they disguise it with
such as prologues has turned many people
away from the product the latest
iteration GT spot is currently in beta
phase and it looks far from complete at
the moment this game will support psvr
and could be in a league of its own if
it's done successfully sorry I don't
sound too optimistic about this one it
does worry me a little I hope I am wrong
[Music]
Detroit become human is from the
brilliantly messed up mind of David cage
and his Quantic Dream Studio he has made
us do some messed up things in the past
especially in heavy rain with cut off
our finger
[Music]
and we've watched our own flesh and
blood die Jason Jason Jason
Nathan
well the team are back four destroyed to
become human which is centered around
Android and their place in society in
the preview we witness many ways to end
a hostage situation including the very
worst thing you can imagine
but if you play the game the correct way
you should be able to save that little
girl
[Music]
and it's the truth
[Music]
Quantic Dream's specialize in multi
decision-making storytelling so this one
could be played by five different people
who all received different endings to
iTunes , how brilliant was the last of
us a freaking masterpiece I'm sure you
will agree the recent announcement of
the Last of Us part two have got tongues
wagging about a potential release date
my guess would be 2019 but I'm hoping
I'm wrong and Naughty Dog's the death
behind the last of us are further along
than I expect if you didn't play the
first one then get your life started and
play it now I'll wait the gameplay and
the narrative are exquisite in the first
title and we are told that the Last of
Us part two is focused around revenge
and anger which has led some people to
believe the protagonists from the first
title joel's have died and he's only a
figment of Elly's imagination in the
trailer as soon as more information
becomes available I'll be sure to bring
it straight to you another game which I
believe is years away is death stranding
I believe 2020 will be the release year
but maybe 2019 had to push he the
Okajima the mastermind behind the Metal
Gear Solid series has broken away from
Konami
whether he jumped or was pushed is still
up for debate the trailers for death
stranding are a bit of a mind and
involve Darrell from The Walking Dead
who also played stood in blade remember
that no just makes you wrong okay anyway
he's here alongside Guillermo del Toro
and Mads Mikkelsen and a spooky baby in
a jar what more could you want no one
has a clue what's going on
so book a look and enjoy whatever kijima
throws at us next oh and by the way
there are some really cool desk trending
Easter eggs in another ps4 exclusive
horizon zero dawn so I'll link them at
the end of the video it's a great time
to be a PlayStation gamer for the sheer
number of exclusives alone I haven't had
a chance to mention Uncharted The Lost
Legacy the Final Fantasy 7 remake all
wild knack - if anybody wants that Ace
Combat VR and hell-blade to name drop
but of view what do you think of these
titles excited by any
I cannot wait to get my hands on days
gone it looks absolutely epic I imagine
from PlayStation grenade I'll catch you
next time